on this episode we talk to da ki about
how they use federated learning to
preserve privacy while training machine
learning models so going back to your
application you kind of mentioned that
AI was used for the patients that are
using it tell us a little bit more about
the actual app yep so we have the
medical research companion app and what
it allows you to do is basically be able
to collect some important omics
information and we have reduced the
friction to be able to collect that like
I mentioned earlier you can take medical
selfie which is just a selfie but it
extracts medical information out of that
we can extract mood and behavioral data
out of that selfie but we can also take
pictures off your pill bottles and
understand what medication and dosage
and instructions that exist on those we
can do that pretty much for lab results
and medical records very soon we can
also collect your genetic information so
we don't do wet sequencing meaning that
we don't get you sequenced but we can
collect any of the raw data that you
have sequenced yourself for example from
23andme your ancestry and be able to
bring that into the app and keep it in
the app and then understand what's in
the data right so so one is it's all
about Polly omits data collection that
the app allows you to do but on the
other side we basically run what we call
as data trials which is the new version
of what medical research looks like
where we can actually take users
vertically based on their disease or
conditions and use the data they've
collected so far to like lead them
towards this research with the right
consent and the right opt-ins so that
they can participate and get some
rewards the rewards could be financial
but it will also be more than that like
insights and other predictions that we
can give on top of that so largely it
the medical companion app is a medical
research app that are those patients to
understand and see what are the newer
ways that they can find solutions for
their diseases today how does the cloud
kind of enable that color
and then you know actual yeah using of
that data right yeah so we see that in
many ways so first of all for some
something like medical selfie which is
basically a deep learning model that we
have built we have built it on the club
across a lot of data that we were able
to collect painstakingly through
different techniques so the medical
selfie is a deep learning model that can
take an image or a selfie of your face
and be able to predict your sex height
weight and age as parameters out of that
but then also triage further predictions
out of that so now that's a model that
we built on the cloud using on Google
cloud using a lot of computational
resources then we were able to convert
that model to run on a mobile device so
we we were able to take that and made it
to edge inferences so we can run it on a
phone and it can actually predict those
variables just sitting on the phone
without really revealing or taking any
of the images that they pay patient or
the member is taking back to the server
so so one thing that I see there is that
cloud enables us to like build models
like this that today is much harder to
build just on the phone but with newer
approaches like federated learning we
can actually also train and build models
on the phone across many many many users
like hundreds of thousands of users so
we may not need cloud to even centralize
the data at some point in future so what
exactly does federated learning an able
for the users who are using the
application that's a great question so I
think healthcare data in general is a
very valuable data asset and I think
it's highly secure and private data that
every user and every patient should
actually care for so we think the future
of where all of the health information
will exist is only on the edge
specifically on the mobile phones for
the users and I think it's easy for them
to lose that information and send it to
a cloud if they are not aware of how the
data has been used so what we can do
with federated learning now is
provide guarantees for users that it can
stay on the device but then we don't
lose the aspect of learning something
from the data we're in we can now build
models that can train on the device and
we can build a better model on the
server
by just sort of sharing the device
trained information which is usually
like bits of information like numbers
but not the real data itself and imagine
now if we can do that across a
population of users like hundreds of
thousands of users then what we get
behind the scenes is a much more robust
model that's much more diverse and
hopefully it's much more generalized
than as if it was strain on a single
user so that's what federated learning
can do and then we can add layers of
security and tools like differential
privacy where we don't even learn
anything about the person that we are
training on so in combination with
differential privacy and federated
learning I think we have a very
important solution where we can keep the
data on the edge and still be able to
learn something from the data without
knowing who the user is or what's in the
data stay tuned for more conversations
with Balki i if you enjoyed this episode
check out the stack chat playlist for
more great videos
[Music]
you